[Music]
project Almanac or welcome to yesterday
as it was originally going to be called
when it was supposed to come out last
year is a found-footage time travel
movie produced by Michael Bay about a
whole bunch of kids who discover plans
for a time machine they then tried to
build and create this thing test it and
see if they could actually go back in
time and of course they can't and like
most teenagers they decide well it'd be
really cool to go to some concerts we
wanted to go to or maybe go back and
take that test that we failed or maybe
talk to that girl that we like again and
do it better this time
that's understandable cuz if I was their
age I'd probably want to do the same
thing but then eventually I'd want to go
meet Abraham Lincoln or see George
Washington or go all the way back to
when Alexander the Great was ruling or
something and of course that never
happens because all these kids want to
do is get a girl and of course
eventually the ripple effect takes place
and bad things start to happen and all
of a sudden it's not really that cool
anymore to travel through time and don't
get me wrong I didn't hate this movie
there were definitely some enjoyable
parts to it namely some of the special
effects were very well done and that
they were convincing enough they didn't
look larger-than-life they didn't look
overblown they added something to the
movie and I like that also the kids have
pretty good chemistry with one another
they get along well and there are some
entertaining moments and it's kind of
cool at first when you can just see them
jump back and forth through time and
change certain things you know the kind
of stuff that you would do at the very
beginning but then they continue to only
do that they don't do anything really
amazing or cool they just kind of go
like well I didn't really like the
conversation I had with that girl I
liked so I'm gonna do it again after a
while you kind of want some more meat
you know and you just don't get it with
this movie this movie's idea of
character development is dude you gotta
go talk to her oh my god I think she
looked your way man are you gonna go low
you're gonna go talk to her I think she
likes you man in regards to character
they're just really there to hold the
camera and it'd be really shaky now
let's talk about that the found-footage
element to this movie I can't help but
compare it to Chronicle and earth to
echo two more recent found footage films
that are similar in their science
fiction like elements with every single
found footage movie there is always what
I call the excuse there's always a
character that states an excuse for why
they are filming everything this movie
has one as well but the problem with
this
movie is and the problem with almost
every found footage movie nowadays that
gets under my skin is that it's trying
to set up some severe hyperrealism
and yet every shot looks incredibly
professional with its lighting and of
course with its sound I mean if these
really are just teenagers in school
where are they getting these incredible
cameras that can film sound at a
professional Hollywood level when two
people are standing like a hundred feet
away now I know I'm sort of nitpicking
there but I don't really think I am I'm
really tired of found-footage movies not
being found footage movies this movie
looks professional okay the lighting is
amazing and the audio is awesome these
kids don't have these capabilities and
so it really just feels like it should
be a movie like earth to echo last year
that's the same problem I had with earth
to echo I was like this would probably
be a really entertaining movie if it was
just a movie and it wasn't like hey
whole bunch of kids found some footage
and it edited it together really fast
with a whole bunch of modern-day pop
songs it's like why is this even a found
footage movie I'll tell you why because
they can easily make their budget back
that's it guys in this movie it's the
epitome of a gimmick there's no reason
for this movie to be found footage at
all I'm tired of these found-footage
movies with these kids who are supposed
to be filming everything but
everything's always in perfect focus
no one's ever oversaturated the white
balance is never out of control it's
always perfect so that's my rant about
the technical side of this movie and
almost all found-footage movies nowadays
but the characters in this movie just
aren't interesting they don't do
anything cool except oh wow let's do a
spring break time jumping marathon and
it's just it's dumb after a while you
can't really get into that it just
doesn't really get you into the film
because you're just watching all bunch
of kids have fun with the time-travel
machine which would be cool for about a
half an hour maybe but not for the
entire runtime guys this movie just
didn't really work for me there were
moments where it was fun the kids have
good chemistry with one another but
overall it's really just a found footage
excuse to hopefully make their budget
back I'm gonna give project Almanac a
c-minus you can sit and watch this movie
you're not going to hate the experience
of watching this movie more than likely
but you aren't really going to remember
it probably for much longer
guys thank you so much as always for
watching and I want to remind you about
my Toonami video I'm making very soon my
first episode of retro rewind
about this a lot but I can finally
announce it'll be out in a couple days
because I got all the submissions for my
celebrity guests they're all done it's
all ready to go and I can't wait to show
it to you guys it's my first ever
episode of this segment
speaking of anime I will also have a
review of the anime kids on the slope
really soon this is an anime by
Shinichiro Watanabe the director of
cowboy bebop and samurai Champloo I
watched it recently and I'm really
excited to talk to you guys about it if
you wanted to watch it before my review
I am currently running a promotion
through crunchyroll right now you guys
can have 30 days of this anime streaming
service for free
crunchyroll does have kids on the slope
on there if you guys want to watch it
before my review if you go to
crunchyroll.com slash chris stuckman you
can get 30 days of crunchyroll for free
they have tons of anime on this site all
in HD and quite often we get it very
soon too when Japan actually has it
released which is unprecedented really
this site is run by people who really
care about anime who love anime and
there's no ads that's so great so go to
crunchyroll.com slash chris Duckman you
get 30 days for free it's my gift to you
guys it is no obligation seriously it's
just like hey here enjoy that I'm trying
to do more promotions like this on my
channel that give you guys cool free
stuff and since I am going to be
reviewing kids on the slopes soon it'd
be cool for you guys to actually get a
chance to watch it before I talk about
it guys as always thank you so much for
watching I did also see the loft this
weekend I'll have a review for that very
soon as always I really appreciate you
guys watching and thank you so much if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck Benoist
[Music]